There she is.
That's the thief.
That's the woman who stole your heart, sir?
She stole my heart.
Wait, what?
How could you!?
You said I was the only one!
I told him I didn't want a relationship.
Ain't my fault dicks don't quit.
Arrest her!
She stole my heart.
Okay, well that's technically not even a crime.
If you gave her your heart that's actually a gift.
It might be tax-deductible, you could check into that
with your accountant if you have one--
*sobbing*
You know once you give her your heart--
*sobs louder*
Which one is the aronist, sir?
Number 2.  She's the one who set my passion aflame.
Wait, why are you even upset about that?
That sounds amazing.
I haven't connected with a woman in so long
it's like every time we get close it just goes like
Eh.  There's like Tinder and J-Swipe--all this stuff out there.
How do you ever know that someone is the one?
There's so many options nowadays.
That's the one.
That's the murderer.
Oh let me guess, she murdered your chance at love.
Or she killed your hopes and dreams.
Or she put an end to the idea of a happy life together.
No man, she murdered my wife in front of me.
Oh.
And then she yelled out "Yahtzee"
Thank you, Big Red.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Man, that is a good question.  I honestly don't know.
I mean, I was an only child so I feel like it starts there.
Ate too much sugar cereal.
Which I think is like a big thing for a kid
--it's like a bad thing.
I used to finger barbies.  Something is wrong with me.
I don't have time to go to therapy, I'm really busy.
I was telling the other guy that--but something is wrong.
Something is really wrong.
Yahtzee!
[Maniacal Laughter]